the Louisiana Purchase not only was
probably the best real estate deal in
history it was also one of the formative
events in American history and it really
defined the country as we know it today
France owned Louisiana territories which
is a vast expanse of wilderness at that
point along the banks of the Mississippi
River and extending all the way to the
Rockies and beyond it was about eight
hundred thousand square miles of
territory the United States was very
concerned because the Port of New
Orleans through which half of America's
trade flowed out as a port of entry from
the Mississippi had been cut off to the
Americans
it sent America in its first real major
crisis since the Revolution and Napoleon
sold it to the United States because he
was worried that he might lose it anyway
if a war broke out with the British
which seemed imminent and eventually
happened the u.s. bought Louisiana
territories for fifteen million dollars
and it forms the basis for the majority
of our states today
was aware that France and Napoleon was
about to go to war with England he
needed money for the war and he was
worried that he would lose Louisiana
anyway so the American negotiators
successfully used this to their
advantage and one of the lessons we can
draw from that is if you understand what
motivates the person on the other side
of the table from you whether in a real
estate negotiation or a business
negotiation you may discover factors
that don't involve you directly but to
push the other side under pressure to
make a deal or provide leverage that you
can use for instance if you're if you're
buying a house you may discover that the
other side is selling the house because
the family has gotten a new job
elsewhere and needs to move by a certain
date that gives you leverage in the
negotiation because they're under
pressure to sell there may be other
factors that that are there that are
involved but but if they have to sell
then that gives you additional leverage
that you can use to lower the price to
improve the terms to do any number of
things